All set up boss.
Actually, he's the boss.
I just pay for everything,
and design everything,
make everyone look cooler.
The Avengers, how can you possibly stop me?
Show him what we got.
Time to work for a living.
That just slipped.
Hey big guy. *growl*
That's all in the swing.
If you step out that door,
you're an Avenger.
You didn't see that coming?
Alright, it's time for some fun.
Hey youtubers, it's Charlie, so Marvel just confirm
that the Russo brothers are gonna be directing Avengers: Infinity War Parts 1 and 2.
They're taking over for Joss
Whedon on the Avengers franchise.
I know a lot of you are asking why is Joss Whedon leaving? Just because he' not directing
Infinity War, doesn't mean he's not
going to be involved with the project.
Whedon is still something of a creative
director for their film unit.
After the first Avengers film, they're
gangbusters of the box office,
Marvel went to Whedon, and turned him into something of creative director for
all their films and TV shows, anything
that they do really inside Marvel Studios.
That means whenever they're evaluating
new projects or they're trying to touch
up scripts for anything that they're
doing,
they send them to Whedon. He was a big
influence on James Gunn's Guardians of the Galaxy.
Gunn said that when he was writing the
script for Guardians, he went to Whedon for advice
and Whedon said 'make it more James Gunn' which I think is just a great thing to tell someone.
It says a lot about James Gunn that Whedon thought that Guardians needed more James Gunn in the script
He was mostly talking James Gunn's sense of humor and his timing. And obviously it pay off big time.
Now Guardians of the Galaxy is just as big a franchise
as the Avengers. And that's why, I know
a lot of you're asking, James Gunn's name
wasn't in the hat
for Avengers: Infinity War. I'm sure people
talked about it behind the scene, I'm sure it was
talked about, but beecause he's ramping up for Guardians 2,
and there's no way they're not gonna do
a Guardians 3, he wouldn't have time to
fit two Avengers films back to back in.
Just a quick update on the Marvel Phase
3 schedule. So I know a lot of you ask me
to include Spider-Man in.
Technically it's not a Phase 3 film, but
because they're sharing the character
Marvel has a lot of creative input,
you could call the next Spider-Man film a Phase 3 film.
And that's where the Russo brothers
come in because they are attached to the
new Spider-Man franchise that Sony's
launching.
It's a little mind blowing but it makes
sense when you look at the big picture.
if you're not familiar with the Russo
brothers, the ones that are directing
Infinity War,
they're the ones that did Winter Soldier. They're also getting ready to shoot
Captain America: Civil War, starting April 1st.
That movie is gonna debuted next spring,
in 2016.
After that, what's going to happen is
that they just signed a contract with Sony,
they're going to develop the Spider-Man franchise for them. Let's look at the full line-up,
including spider-man, so,
we start with Captain America: Civil War
coming out May 6th 2016,
Doctor Strange is next, November 4th 2016,
Guardians of the Galaxy 2 is May 5th 2017,
then Spider-Man,
that for spider-man in the new franchise, that comes out July 28th 2017,
the Russos are probably gonna be involved
with that. They haven't been announced to
direct it, but they signed a development deal with Sony, so they probably gonna be attatched to in some way.
They'll either produce it or they will also sign on to direct it.
The Thor 3, Ragnarok, comes out November 3rd 2017,
then the first Avengers: Infinity War at the beginning of 2018,
then Black Panther during the summer and
Captain Marvel at the end of 2018, so
there's three Marvel movies in 2018.
Then Infinity War Part 2 is gonna be in
spring 2019,
then Inhumans comes out that same year. So basically what the Russos are gonna do
is they're gonna do Captain America: Civil War next, then they're gonna jump to Sony
work on Spider-Man, then come back
to Marvel for Infinity War.
So they're like the busiest people on
Hollywood right now. And speaking of busy,
I know a lot of your asking why is Joss Whedon leaving the project? I already mentioned, he's
probably gonna stay on as producer, so technically
he's not leaving the project, he's just taking a diminished role,
so that he has more free time. Directing
any kinda film is a huge job,
even small films. When you direct a big
franchise movie like Avengers, especially
a two-part movie,
that's like 4-5 years in someone's life
that you just have to throw away. It's 24 hours a
day, 7 days a week, 365 days a year
until the project is out. There were a lot of
reporters that went to do interviews
with Whedon while they were filming Age of Ultron and they said when they saw him on set
he kinda looked like a walking ghost, like he was so tired.
He knew it was going to be his last
Marvel film, at the time, you know, maybe it wasn't
confirmed yet,
and he wanted go to every single meeting  he could possibly go to.
That's how awesome he is. Whedon basically wanted to give input on like
every little prop that was in the movie,
any little detail that he felt he could touch up.
Most really big directors on films like that would just delegate to their
department heads.
So Whedon is basically going to be taking a very, very long nap after Avengers: Age of Ultron is out.
But he will still be a producer on
Marvel films. What Marvel's working on right
now, and now that they have the Russos, is they're working on getting
the same team that wrote Captain America: Civil War to write Infinity War.
So the same team that made Winter Soldier and is making Captain America: Civil War
will also be making Infinity War. Anytime
like a really awesome team gets together,
studios do everything they can to keep
them together, just because by the time a
team gets to their second or third
film the machine that they've created
just works so well. And that's what Marvel wants,
they want predictability,
they want predictable success. So if
you're a big fan of Winter Soldier,
you'll probably love Civil War and you
probably really enjoy Infinity War.
It's a little too early to predict what's
going to be going on that movie so I
wanna make too many predictions, obviously we know Thanos probably
going to assemble the Gauntlet, create some havoc they'll have to clean up in
the second part of the movie.
We don't know anything about a potential Guardians crossover. The more
successful guardians of the Galaxy is,
the less likely Marvel is going to be
really urgent to have a crossover with the Avengers.
I think that was one of the reasons why
James Gunn was so quick to dismiss any
potential crossovers in the first part
of Infinity War ,with the Guardians.
He's like 'we created this big universe
over here, let's give it some time to
breathe before start matching it up with
everyone else'
So there is gonna build out the Guardians universe before they try to
crossover with the Avengers universe,
even though technically it's all in continuity together. I know it's a little
confusing when you talk about Marvel's
phases.
As for Guardians of the Galaxy 3, that
probably won't land till Marvel Phase 4.
Just expect a new guardians movie like every two years. After the third film tough, all bets are off.
Usually at that point the actors have appeared in so many films that they have to
renegotiate contracts.
But yes, Chris Pratt, all those Guardians
actors, signed the same six picture deal
that everyone else in the Avengers
franchises did. So here's my big question for
you guys how do you feel about the
Russo brothers
taking over for Joss Whedno on the Avengers franchise? Winter Soldier was a
very different type a film
than either of the Avengers films, but
Marvel's creative unit does a really good
job of keeping directors and writers
consistent within the universe, so it's
not gonna be like a dramatic departure,
it won't look completely different.
So if you want to get a sense for
character dynamics and the dialogue just
watch Winter Soldier again,
and obviously watch Civil War whenever it
comes out. I think Civil War will be a
better template too because they'll have
so many more
Avengers inside a bit. They're a lot of people that are starting to call Captain America: Civil War
"Avengers 2.5" just because there are so
many Avengers in it.
They're taking most of the cast from Age of Ultron, not everyone, but most of the cast
and kinda changing the rolls up. It'll be
like the Avengers splitting in two.
So I'm really interested to see like which half the Avengers from
Age of Ultron side with Iron Man,
and which half side with Captain America. I'm really hoping some of the next couple films
tease out Josh Brolin's Thanos because I
think he'll appear in Guardians 2,
hopefully in a bigger way. But we really
have no idea which of the other Avengers films
he's gonna appear in,
if any. It's entirely likely that we won't see him at all during Age of Ultron,
he doesn't seem as relevant to the story
as he does during Guardians of the Galaxy.
I think my next Marvel movie videos is gonna be like the top five new
characters I'd like to see in Infinity War,
so be sure to subscribe to get that, I'll
try and post that later this week.
In case you guys haven't seen it, I just did like a fun Loki-Age of Ultron-Thor: Ragnarok video,
you can click here to watch that and you can click here for all my other Marvel Phase 3 videos.
Thank you so much watching, let's all high-five, I'll see you guys tonight.